Let's talk today for a while about how governments
can and should deal with recessions.
This is an important question right now.
The unemployment rate is skyrocketing.
More than 20 million people, 20, 24, 23 million
people have lost their jobs in the last five
weeks.
We learned today that GDP was down almost
5 percent in the first quarter of the year.
We are seeing some ideas that second quarter
GDP could be down as much as 20 percent or
even more.
So we have a serious situation here, recession,
depression.
And we need to think about what are the options
for what governments can do.
What has Trump done and is he doing a good
job or isn't he doing a good job?
And what I want to suggest to you today.
Is that given the circumstances?
Donald Trump has actually used most of the
correct measures that are available under
the paradigm of Keynesian economics to deal
with the recession.
But he's done it in a completely incompetent
crony and slow way.
And these are policies that are direct contradictions
to what Republicans claim are the policies
that a government should institute.
So there's also an element of hypocrisy.
But we'll get to that.
So to start with.
Governments have two major sets of sort of
tools at their disposal, monetary policy and
fiscal policy.
And very simply, when we say fiscal policy,
we mean government spending to influence the
economy.
And when we say monetary policy, we're talking
about treasury management.
In our case, it's whoever manages the currency,
treasury management of the money supply and
of interest rates.
So fiscal policy would include things like
spending on infrastructure during a recession
to create jobs, hire businesses to fix bridges,
the businesses, pay those employees that are
doing the work.
Those employees then go and spend that money
in the economy, helping the grocery store
and the landscaping company then hire and
they hire and so on and so forth.
So it's fiscal policy.
Then you've got monetary policy.
Monetary policy would be, for example, cutting
interest rates to encourage loans, making
loans cheaper so that people will go and borrow
money with which they can pay for expenses,
buy things, maybe pay employees, et cetera.
When Corona virus hits, businesses start to
close.
People stop traveling.
A bunch of things happen without government
into an intervention that aren't good.
This increases unemployment.
Naturally, there is a demand collapse.
People stopped going to restaurants.
So the restaurant no longer needs their workers.
So they lay them off, which means the restaurant
owner isn't making any money.
They can't pay their rent or maybe they can't
pay their utilities.
So that affects their landlord.
The restaurant doesn't have customers, so
it doesn't need to buy food.
So they stop spending with the food supplier.
The food supplier doesn't need to buy as much
stuff from farmers.
The farmers no longer need as many employees.
I think you can sort of understand that.
Now, the food example is a more interesting
one because you see a demand reduction at
restaurants, but an increase at grocery stores.
But as we've learned with toilet paper, oftentimes
the personal and commercial supply chains
for some of these goods are separate.
So that's sort of a detail.
But I think you generally understand the the
idea here.
The other thing that can happen in a recession
is that you get a deflationary spiral.
So in the same way that if everybody wants
hand sanitizer, the price of sanitizer gets
driven up, up, up, which we saw about seven,
eight weeks ago.
If, for example, nobody's driving around,
this leads to a drop in oil and gasoline prices,
which we've seen now.
We may not care that much about oil prices
being low.
It sounds intuitive that lower prices are
just good, right?
I mean, if we're in a recession and stuff
costs less, that's good.
It means people can afford more of it.
The problem is that it can cause more unemployment
if you run a business.
And suddenly not only do people want less
of your stuff, but you have to lower the price
because people aren't willing to pay as much
for it.
That further is not being able to keep employees
on.
So you lay people off, which means they don't
have money to buy stuff, which means the deflation
continues.
That's why it's called a spiral in a healthy
economy.
You might see some deflation because we get
better at making something.
So if we become much more efficient at making
a particular product, we lower our cost to
make each one of those items.
And as companies compete with each other,
whoever can increase productivity and lower
costs can maybe gain more market share.
So that's OK.
That's a good example of prices coming down.
Deflation deflationary spirals in a recession
aren't good.
So let's now look at the things Donald Trump
has done or things that that have been done,
if not by Donald Trump personally.
So the Fed cut interest rates.
Great.
That's monetary policy.
That's the right thing to do.
The Treasury has created these P.P. programs,
paycheck protection plan programs where the
interest rate is its effect, effectively negative.
You get money.
And as long as you use it for the right things,
the loan doesn't have to be paid back in full.
That's the correct thing to do.
Now, the problem is they did it in the crony
capitalist way that Trump always seems to
do.
It took too long.
There were all sorts of logistical failures.
The system didn't actually start distributing.
Money for a month or longer.
Money ran out too quickly.
A lot of the money went to really large corporations
and other institutions instead of small businesses.
Small businesses ended up not being able to
get money.
Trump has to scramble.
Ask for more money and ask for money back.
Total disaster in its implementation.
But it is policy that makes sense.
Now there's a practical way in which peopIe
is kind of a blend of monetary and fiscal
policy.
It's sort of like low interest loans, which
is monetary, but forgivable loans to business
are sort of like government spending, which
is fiscal policy, but that's kind of a detail
in terminology.
Another important monetary policy component
is expectations management.
This is part of why, remember, we talked last
week or the week before we get bad unemployment
news.
And yet the stock market sometimes goes up.
What's going on?
Managing expectations is part of monetary
policy.
You tell the public in advance what you expect
to see happen so that it more smoothly.
This is the goal, right?
It more smoothly gets priced into the markets.
And then when the news hits, it's not a shock
to the system because the markets were expecting
it anyway.
That is a form of monetary policy.
Expectations management.
So let's now talk about fiscal stimulus.
You can do fiscal stimulus by cutting taxes.
So when Trump proposed, that didn't happen.
But Trump proposed what if we do a waiver
or a moratorium on the payroll tax until the
end of the year?
That would be a form of fiscal stimulus through
a tax cut.
You can also do fiscal stimulus by the government
spending money.
This can be buying things.
This can be hiring companies to do stuff.
It can also be just the government sending
people checks could be a one time payment,
which we've seen could be by increasing unemployment
benefits.
What we're talking about is deficit spending.
There are sort of people on the right who
like the cartoon ify this as printing money.
We talked last week with Stephanie Kelton
about that.
Calling it printing money is not really an
accurate term.
What we're talking about is deficit spending.
We're talking about digitally adding money
to people's accounts.
Now, again, Trump is doing this.
He's boosting unemployment benefits.
That's fiscal policy.
It's getting money to people which people
can then spend increasing aggregate demand,
maintain prices relatively level more level
than they otherwise would be.
When Trump cuts twelve hundred dollar checks,
really the Treasury does.
That's fiscal policy.
It's government spending.
Now, they also sent billions to some industries,
airlines, cruise companies.
That's also fiscal stimulus and it is the
right tool.
But the problem has been, again, implementation
took way too long.
Not nearly enough money for the average individual.
A ton of the spending was done with companies.
That really shouldn't be the priority.
Should've been more money for individuals.
We heard last week from billionaire investor
Tomas Polish Pedia who said that, you know,
some of the companies being bailed out, these
are really bailing out.
These are bailouts of the billionaires who
are speculating, not the employees.
If you really want to bail out employees,
you can do it in a much more direct way.
In addition, Trump has done it in a completely
crony capitalist way.
He's reduced oversight, which has turned some
of these bailout funds into essentially slush
funds.
He's used government money to buy things like
ventilators and PPE.
That's stimulus.
Except there's always something weird when
Trump does it, like the company that is bankrupt
with no employees, which has gotten a big
contract to essentially just middleman the
purchase of a bunch of masks way above market
value.
So it's the right tool.
It's being done in a crony capitalist way.
The focus is often wrong.
It took forever.
Millions have still got nothing.
The you know, the unemployment insurance supplements
have still not been received by a lot of people.
So in short, Donald Trump has used the right
tools under the Keynesian paradigm.
And I'll talk more about that in a second.
Fiscal policy, monetary policy.
But he's done it in an incompetent way.
And it, of course, is, of course, massive
hypocrisy, because what we hear from the right
year in and year out is, one, we don't have
the money for this.
That's clearly untrue.
We found it right.
And again, it's not really finding it.
That's a misnomer.
But we were able to do it despite Republicans
saying it's not possible.
So there's the hip, hip hypocrisy element.
And number two, you often hear Republicans
saying that these types of techniques don't
actually work.
And yet here they are saying we've actually
got to do it.
So incompetence and hypocrisy, but the right
tools have been used.
Now, what hasn't Trump done that he could
have done infrastructure spending? Trump has
talked about doing infrastructure spending.
It would be important to do six solid months
of infrastructure spending.
So have the government.
Spend on fixing roads, bridges, tunnels, the
electric grid could be bolstered.
Water supply could be better protected.
There's tons of things that could be done.
They would boost employment.
They would inject money.
And when we come out of this, whenever it
is, we would be better prepared.
We would have better infrastructure to resume
all of that economic activity.
It's not been done.
It's time to do it.
Trump should have already gotten this going.
He talks.
Maybe it'll happen in the next phase.
We don't know.
That certainly has been a mistake.
Now, let's zoom out from all of this.
Why?
Everything I've been talking about, these
fiscal policy tools, these are what we call
Keynesian tools.
They're from the School of Fiscal Policy founder
John Maynard Keynes.
Our government has these tools available instead
of other tools, because Keynesian economics
are sort of the orthodoxy.
And this is based on you see a recession fundamentally
as a demand shortage.
And you then take these reactions of fiscal
policy that we've described.
That is not the only way to see the role of
government before and during a recession or
depression.
A more progressive economic worldview would
say, all right, David, you accurately described
the Keynesian tools, but those tools are not
proactive.
They are reactive.
So I'll give you some examples of what a more
progressive, proactive perspective would be.
A more progressive economic perspective would
say the federal government should always be
bolstering state unemployment insurance.
So if they did that all along and people got
more money from unemployment insurance, if
more money was available at the state level,
then you wouldn't see this panicked scramble
to do it now.
But you wouldn't see the decrease in demand
that you are seeing now because people don't
have money.
Another perspective, the federal government
should always be funding more education and
other government jobs so that when you have
a recession, a lot of those jobs just continue
and you avoid having to bail out as many companies
with loans.
You avoid having to send as many people.
Twelve hundred dollar checks because a lot
of these government jobs, including in education,
can simply continue.
Now, there's a that's that's a political perspective
that right wingers often disagree with.
Others would say if we had permanent universal
basic income, we would obviate the need for
as much of this desperate spending because
people would already be getting that baseline
income from the government.
And thus this pandemic recession would be
less of an emergency.
It would still be one, but it would be less
of an emergency if we had.
Here we go now.
Government run health care.
You wouldn't need Trump negotiating with insurance
companies to waive co-pays on corona virus
testing or treatment.
It would simply be done because the government
is more involved in health care.
So that exceeds our time today.
But the seed I'm planting is Trump has used
the right tools given the system we have.
He's used them incompetently, but there are
more progressive economic perspectives which
would say if we had much more government involvement
all along in employment, in fiscal policy
all the time, it would prevent as much of
an emergency need for that to be done right
now.
Many people don't want more government involvement
and that's a political debate.
So I hope that this is useful to people.
There's been a clamoring for more policy stuff
like this.
I'll produce what the people want.
Let me know.
Your thoughts on this particular segment on
Twitter at The David Pakman Show David Pakman.